harry potter scribe jk rowling has
created a wizarding world that has
sparked the imaginations of millions
across the globe and while her
accomplishments have made her a very
rich and powerful person
that doesn't mean she lives entirely
without regret to many fans the decision
to pair ron weasley with hermione
granger was a strange one
ron the goofy sidekick had almost
nothing in common with hermione whereas
harry always recognized her status as
the secret mvp of the story central trio
sure ron had a few moments of bravery
and there was that tenuous connection
with her being a muggle and his dad
having a fascination with the
non-wizarding world but please
even rawling knows that hermione and
harry were the real end game of the
series
in an interview with the sunday times
rowling admitted i wrote the hermione
wrong relationship as a form of wish
fulfillment
that's how it was conceived really for
reasons that have very little to do with
literature
and far more to do with me clinging to
the plot as i first imagined it
hermione ended up with ron it was a
choice i made for very personal reasons
not for reasons of credibility of course
it's possible that the personal reason
she's alluding to here is the fact that
ron weasley was based on a closed
childhood friend of hers
while hermione was based in part upon
herself
mentor that one i'm telling you in 2007
jk rowling revealed that albus
dumbledore was meant to be a gay
character even if it wasn't completely
spelled out in her books
during a reading of harry potter and the
deathly hallows she answered a fan
question as to whether dumbledore had
ever fallen in love saying
dumbledore is gay actually while the
news was received warmly by the crowd
she expressed some regret that she
hadn't been more clear about that before
saying
i would have told you earlier if i knew
it would make you so happy
the matter would become a point of
contention later on however when
dumbledore's sexuality was again
left ambiguous in fantastic beasts the
crimes of grindelwald
lgbtq advocates were dismayed when
director david yates revealed that the
film would not explicitly address his
homosexuality
although rowling still openly defended
her decision to make dumbledore gay
she chose to ignore those who criticized
the film's lack of attention to that
detail
for the third installment in the
franchise yates has maintained that they
will make dumbledore's romantic history
with grindelwald a little more obvious
rowling fielded more public
disappointment over the fact that the
cast for the first fantastic beasts was
predominantly white
producer david heyman defended the
film's casting by explaining that the
story's timeline had a lot to do with
the cast's whiteness
pointing out to entertainment weekly
that 1920s era new york was racially
segregated
he said the wizarding world is a much
more open and tolerant society where
people of color and different ethnic
backgrounds exist harmoniously together
heyman also promised that the series
would have people of color filling this
world in an organic way
rowling meanwhile simply denied that the
cast was all white on twitter and
challenged a fan to wait to see the
movie before judging adding
it is a trilogy and all the characters
have not been revealed or cast yet
the author faced further fantastic
beasts backlash when the character of
nagini
voldemort's pet snake from the original
series was introduced in the crimes of
grindelwald as a maledictus
played by the south korean actress
claudia kim rowling was accused of
fabricating diversity with the decision
which she fought back against by
pointing out that the word nagini comes
from indonesian mythology and that
indonesia has a significant chinese
population
still as many suspected the character
came through as something of a token
inclusion in the movie
all of this comes on top of other
long-running potter franchise
controversies such as the issue of
jewish representation and varying
interpretations of hermione's race
it's not hard to imagine that given the
chance she would have approached the
diversity of her characters a little
differently
plenty of characters died in harry
potter and the deathly hallows but one
of the offings that hurt the most was
fred weasley who was killed in an
explosion
at the battle of hogwarts fred had
become a fan favorite alongside his twin
brother george thanks to his signature
cheery demeanor
she would later apologize to fans for
claiming the fictional life of a
character who was so beloved by readers
in 2015 she tweeted today i would just
like to say
i'm really sorry about fred in 2016
rowling returned to her tradition of
apologizing for a character's authorial
execution
this time she shone the spotlight on
remus lupin the hogwarts defense against
the dark arts professor who also turned
out to be a werewolf
it wasn't just remus death that hit so
hard though he died shortly after his
wife tonks was also killed
which meant that their newborn son teddy
lost both of his parents before he
actually had a chance to know them
just like harry potter had so many years
before rowling issued a series of tweets
apologizing and explaining the need for
lupin's death writing in the interests
of total honesty
i'd also like to confess that i didn't
decide to kill lupin until i wrote order
of the phoenix
arthur lived so lupin had to die i'm
sorry
i didn't enjoy doing it the only time my
editor ever saw me cry
was over the fate of teddy to orphan one
little wizard baby
cruel two of them oof that's just
diabolical
whether or not professor severus snape
actually redeemed himself at the end of
the deathly hallows is up for debate
sure he was working for the good guys
all along and only killed dumbledore so
that draco malfoy wouldn't have to
but he was pretty terrible to harry from
the very start of his tenure at hogwarts
making the generous assumption that he
was trying to teach potter to toughen up
in preparation for his fateful
confrontation with lord voldemort
you can't help but imagine some of that
was him projecting his pure acrimony for
james potter onto the boy who lived
the fandom's split opinion on snape
meant that a good chunk of them would
have been happy if rowling never
apologized for his death
which is why her 2017 commemoration of
the battle of hogwarts ended up being a
little more timid than usual
she tweeted okay here it is please don't
start flame wars over it but this year
i'd like to apologize for killing
whispers snape after all this time
[Music]
always it's almost like she was
apologizing for apologizing
one character that rowling managed to
completely redeem by the time the series
ended was
dobby the house elf when we first met
him he was a completely irritating pest
whose sole purpose was to get harry in
trouble with the dursleys
by the end of the road he was a sweet
little scamp who just wanted to be
free so that he could define his own
loyalties while trying to rescue harry
and griffook from the death eaters
however
dobby was stabbed by bellatrix lestrange
to make his death even more devastating
harry dug his grave by hand and
inscribed it with the words
here lies dobby a free elf rowling
memorialized him in her 2018 tribute
despite the fact that he wasn't a part
of the legendary final battle writing
it's that anniversary again this year i
apologize for killing someone who didn't
die during the hashtag battle of
hogwarts but who laid down his life to
save the people who'd win it i refer of
course
to dobby the house elf another
lamentation jk rowling has made about
the harry potter series is how certain
characters names are so commonly
mispronounced
with hermione granger for example
rowling had to pretty much spell it out
in the text once she discovered that
fans were saying her name incorrectly
rowling has since admitted that the
scene from harry potter and the goblet
of fire in which hermione tells victor
crum to say
hermione instead of hermione was also
meant to be instructional for readers
since the films hadn't come out yet
one named pronunciation that she never
did quite correct however was lord
voldemort whose moniker most fans think
is voldemort
even the films adapted that bit of
elocution
voldemort voldemort
however if rowling had her way fans
would never say the t in his name at all
in 2015 she confirmed this fun fact
about the series conceding
i'm pretty sure i'm the only person who
pronounces it that way
one specific regret jk rowling is cop to
is the type of dog bred by the third
book's nasty aunt marge
in harry potter and the prisoner of
azkaban perry was introduced to uncle
vernon's sister who often used canine
related theories and phrases to analyze
people it's always to do with the mother
you see it all the time with dogs if
there's something wrong with them
then there's something wrong with the
pup clearly her relationship with her
dogs was significant to her character
development
however rowling later said she should
not have chosen bulldogs as her breed
after all
she wrote on pottermore i regret making
aunt marge a breeder of bulldogs as i
now know them to be a non-aggressive
breed
my sister owns one and he's the most
lovable affectionate dog you could hope
to meet
on the other hand they do look grumpy
and on appearance alone seem to suit
aunt marge
there are some harry potter fan theories
that rowling has shown some major
support and respect for while
others have been kindly dispelled by the
author as illegitimate
usually rowling is plain enough about
putting an idea to rest like when she
denied that ron is a younger time
traveling dumbledore
and shut down the theory that draco
malfoy became a werewolf after being
bitten by fenrir greyback
one theory that seems to get rolling
into a tizzy though is the one that
suggests dumbledore may have turned his
phoenix fox into his own horcrux
admittedly the supporting evidence for
the concept is pretty thin
basically the idea is that if voldemort
could store a piece of his existence in
a snake
a bird wouldn't be off the table either
and dumbledore may not have always been
the benevolent soul that we know him to
be
however rowling not only put akibash on
the idea but also expressed personal
offense to it writing the idea that
anybody believes this is strangely
upsetting to me
by the end of the harry potter series jk
rowling had written a whopping 4224
pages about her magical realm
but there was still one scene she
couldn't quite squeeze into the story
in 2007 the author revealed that she
wanted to include a hogwarts graduation
scene in deathly hallows to confirm that
hermione went back to school and
finished while harry ron neville and
some others went straight to work to
clean up voldemort's mess in the
wizarding world
she told fans on pottercast i felt a
huge sadness that i wouldn't write a
graduation scene
i felt sad that the book wasn't going to
end with that feast scene the graduation
scene
a lot of people felt the epilogue was
too sentimental i think to have a
graduation scene on top of what just
happened would have been an absurd bit
of anti-climax
had the scene been included fans would
have seen the trio ride the festivals
away from hogwarts to signify
a fresh new start for them as they
passed over the water
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
you